hi everybody my name is Ellis Hughes I'm
a data science leader at GSK so before
we go forward just want to say all
opinions are my own and do not
necessarily represent that of my
employer all right you can also find me
on various social media sites such as
LinkedIn YouTube GitHub uh and today
I'll be talking about GT and how I went
through adding word as an output to GT
so GT is a fantastic Library made by
richon to help you make fantastic
beautiful tables very very easily all
you have to do to get started is Library
GT drop in your data set put it in GT
and for free you're going to get a
pretty good table just just with that
one line of code there text is left
aligned numbers are right aligned and it
looks pretty good just just from the
GetGo there
but the power of GT isn't just this one
function no it's got a lot more to it in
fact you can make some pretty fantastic
tables using GT there's a ton of syntax
a lot of very easy to ous functions that
allow you to add a lot of complexity to
your tables these are two examples from
the posit table competition that was
held earlier this year I really like how
Georgio the one on the left had images
included in his table he has the little
symbols the icons Rich talked a fair
amount about icons a little bit earlier
today so you know he loves them so you
know you loved he loved this table then
Nicola she included graphs inside of her
table inside of her GT tables are a
fantastic datais tool we just need to
use them
better so we can do some pretty crazy
things with
GT but you typically don't want to leave
them inside of your console right you
don't want to just build them inside of
our studio or wherever you're working
you you need to save them and give them
out to other people and that's where the
GT save function comes in where you pass
in your table object your GT table
object and you pass the file that you'd
like to be going out to in this case
we're going out to HTML but it supports
a wide variety of different outputs like
RTF latch uh you're able to generate pgs
it does some pretty pretty fantastic
things and as of last year August 2022
in
070 word was added as an output to G GT
and that was work that I did with Rich
and so now if you want to go and save
your GT from any sort of output rather
than going out to HTML you simply
replace it with docx and it works and
you've got your table thank
you how much time do I have
left about 17 minutes oh okay well I uh
I do have some backup slides if you if
you don't if you wouldn't mind uh giving
me a moment to go through that as well
uh so our roles as data scientists are
to be reaching out and working with data
SC or uh decision makers stakeholders
people that really need to be making
decisions and so it's our responsibility
to be pulling information out of the
data and giving it to them to
use and so you're a data scientist at
company a and you're looking at a
regression here we're using Mt cars and
looking at MPGs but this could be any
sort of analysis you're per forming and
you generate this output there you're
like great we know what we're supposed
to be doing we've got a fantastic output
but you shouldn't be sending this to
your data or to your decision makers
they have no idea what that means
they're not a data scientist so it's up
to you to figure out how to show it to
them but you're also not like other data
scientists you're a cool data scientist
and you've got all these Fantastic Tools
available for you to be going out to
them you can make interactive plots
we've got we've had a fantastic
presentation on that you can use Corto
you can pick plumber apis our markdown
there's all these wonderful tools
available for us as data scientists
especially our users to make fantastic
outputs thing is you give it to them
they
go that's great but uh if you could give
it to me as a Word document that'd be
I'd like that
better so why why are they asking for a
Word document you just gave them a
beautiful HTML document you made them a
wonderful Flex dashboard that they could
be using well the issue is your boss
works there well and if he doesn't your
boss's boss works there the finance team
marketing team let's face it basically
every team outside of data science is
using word because it's easy to use you
can write a lot of text you can copy and
paste content in there you can write
comments you can do revisions there's so
many tools that exist in word for you to
be using and they're not data scientists
that's where they're comfortable so it's
our responsibility to meet them where
they're at and that's kind of my
experience as well so let's not worry
about the details of the slide here but
really what this is brought up to do or
say is that I was working on a project
where we were trying to build some data
sets were able to go out to a wide
variety of of different outputs there
and our team created a package called t
format
to to facilitate
that and as part of its engine we wanted
to be using the GT package because of
the variety of different outputs it
already had baked in for us we were
really stoked on that one however we had
two types of output that we needed to
support submissions and Intex CSR Intex
csrs which are essentially Word
documents and at the time that we
started working on this this was before
I got involved there had been this issue
that have been open for three years the
possibility to create an AS word
function and it's not like it' just been
sitting there people left
comments people left
comments people left comments and and
and work had been going on but you know
it's a difficult problem to solve um
when I Ste so I reached out to Rich I'm
like hey Rich this problem seems like
it's been there for a while uh would you
mind if I were to help you out let's
talk let's figure out what we can do to
uh make this happen so that's how I got
involved in helping Rich go out to
Word so when I got involved in GT it'
been around for a number of years uh
Rich had introduced GT to the world in
2019 it was actually the first our
studio conference that I went to uh so
it was really exciting to be able to
participate in
that it was at GT version 060 and it
already reported a wide variety of
outputs it went out to HTML I think I'm
probably stepping on something uh HTML
PNG Tech and RTF and for every single
one of those outputs he' created a whole
function to process that table and
convert it to that output he refigured
out every single time for every single
output how it would go and so the same
had to happen for word and he'd done a
fair amount of work on that already he'd
already made 50 commit
he done, 1500 lines of code already and
had a functioning asword function in
there so when I got involved there was a
lot of work to figure out what he
already done what didn't work what what
he' already experimented with and trying
to understand where the problems are
what are the things that he needed to do
so that I could help him out with
that so before we go into how that all
works let's talk about word and Doc
versus Doc X so some of us maybe the
older ones of us will remember the do
DOC format that existed for a long time
so the DOC format is a binary file it's
a proprietary format but really it
hasn't been used since 2007 for our
benefit the docx file however offers a
lot more uh functionality for us it's
actually under the hood it's a zip file
you can actually right click and unzip
Your Word document and see all the cont
contents that's in it it's based on an
office open XML format which is public
and available and you can find it online
um and it was introduced in 2007 and
because it's like that we can also go
out to uh
docx so
yay once you unzip it you'll see a whole
mass of files and realistically you can
kind of ignore most of them the only
file that you need to be concerned about
is the document. XML file and that is
where the body of the contents of your
word document gets contained there's a
lot of other XML files if you're doing
more complicated uh office open XML type
work you will need to deal with them but
for our purposes in this talk let's just
worry about talking it body there so
when I got involved I was like oh XML
I've worked in XML before I've done web
scraping I've played around with these
things before and I know HTML so it's
it's not really going to be that big of
a deal um but it
was in HTML you get to see these
elements that are very clear they're
very well defined not that office open
isn't but it's got the style and then
it's got the uh additional information
about styling and uh then you have hello
world inside of it so if I wanted a pink
Hello World this is the only line of
code you need to be writing uh in
HTML this is what you need to write if
you want to go out to a Word document
pink and bolt there's a fair amount more
code and this is just for the text this
isn't the document body or any of the
other XML that's involved
with
word on top of
that misspelling one thing causes it to
throw an error and you don't know what
caused that
error it's very
helpful so the way that I went about to
learn this and this is really what I
suggest to you as well if you're going
to be involved in a project is take some
time to get some understanding of the
surrounding area what's been going on so
I started reading office uh officeopen
xml.com it's a fantastic resource if you
want to learn about office XML which I
don't know that's up to you um it's a
really great resource on that uh also
while I was working on this it was
really just a lot of trial and error I
would build it out in the word document
see if it or build it out the way that I
thought it should look like save it on
zip it inspect it again go try it code
it up myself try to open it
up and I got a lot of these and a lot
and a
lot and this is something that you may
experience too as you start to go and
help out with new projects is you will
go through some errors you will have
some frustrations but I promise you at
the end of the day when you see this big
blue box saying word is opening or
whatever is for you you're going to be
pretty excited
I did
it and so through a lot of trial and
error a lot of effort a lot of those
error screens and eventually some more
of those blue screens and eventually
more blue screens than
errors um we ended up adding GT or word
to
GT so now going back to our data
scientist they are a cool data
scientists that will meet their leaders
where they're at to help them do their
work so they're going going to take
their linear model throw it into broom
to tidy it up make a nice little uh
tibble there then they're going to throw
it into GT add a header to it add some
coloring to it and save it to a
dockx where they can add a little bit of
their conclusion at the very bottom
there saying you know if we want to
increase the number of cylinders and the
overall weight of the car we can make a
vehicle with a negative
MBG uh and and give that to their senior
leaders to make a decision as to whether
that's you know what they want to go
with so word shapes thoughts msword
shapes documents everyone uses it so GT
and the efforts around word are still
evolving it's only been out for a year
we were still trying to build out a lot
of features it's not my full-time job uh
but recently we added some fun new
features to support formats that GT
supports in HTML we're not going to be
HTML HTML is fantastic it does a lot of
things there's a reason we all love it
but word does a fair amount of things
too and we wanted to try to support that
so first off we now support markdown so
you can write inline markdown inside of
your tibble and it'll go out and throw
it into your GT format GT and you can
still save to a docx that works you can
also add images to your uh Word document
tibbles as or dat GT tables as well so
it supports a variety of those things
however the plethora of formats that
Rich has builtin they're not necessarily
supported so your mileage may
vary additionally styling does need
Improvement as well we're aware uh still
working on that such as tab options but
the way that we can know how we can help
you and the things that you're looking
for is letting us know on the GT Page
open an issue tag it as a word issue so
that we can help make sure that the
contents that you need in GT are
available so you can work with your
decision makers to support them in the
decision- making that they need to be
doing and you know we're experimenting
we're going to be figuring out uh what
are the other things that we could
support now that I have some experience
with office open hopefully you'll join
me and also play around with that uh you
know there's other other outputs at word
or uh that Microsoft supports such as I
don't know PowerPoint is that would you
be interested in that XML or uh Excel I
don't know let us
know next there's a package that I
developed as a developed as a companion
to GT to support folks that like using
officr called the GTO package so the GTO
package allows you to use the G Body ad
GT function to take your GT tables and
add them into your office our pipeline
without doing anything new or different
or
scary and so with that can I have a
word
thank you congratulations on being a
cool data
[Laughter]
scientist as always you can ask
questions via slido um I'm going to ask
one that is not GT related
but I find it very interesting that you
sort of worked in and contributed such a
big feature to a package like GT so um
do you have any advice on anyone looking
at us like o I want to contribute like
this mhm well I mean some of it's just
getting started honestly I didn't have
really any experience with office office
open XML before I got involved in this
project I'd kind of seen it before but I
wasn't familiar with it but I took a
leap of faith that you know rich is a
fantastic guy loved working with him and
most maintainers of Open Source tools
are pretty fantastic people especially
in the our community and so if you're
willing to put in the effort put in the
time trial and error work with them
eventually you can build something that
will you know change the package but
even still it doesn't have to be like a
big contribution right like you can you
can incrementally add things
documentation uh fix a bug or whatever
really open source is a beautiful thing
where you can just help out the with the
tools that you're
using well said um so we do have uh a
question about do you have any plans um
to replicate this for PowerPoint for
PowerPoint open an
issue the XML is a little bit different
in PowerPoint so it will take a little
bit of time and rejiggering and as I
mentioned earlier rewriting how exactly
you do all the styling in uh for
PowerPoint outputs but it's possible in
theory okay
excellent um I think you did such a good
talk that every question is answered for
right now so Fant thank you very
[Applause]
much